salut vous pensez que la réalité qui
nous entoure n'est faite que de hasard
et de conséquence de choix individuels
naïve que vous êtes vous pensiez que la
nature se développe de manière aléatoire
ou que vous êtes en train de regarder de
mes vidéos la tuer de votre plein gré
bon ben moi aussi je pensais ça avant de
rencontrer un truc qui s'appelle la loi
de benford et là mon univers s'est
littéralement nous ne sommes pas si
libre car la loi de benford prouve que
les chiffres aléatoires ne sont en fait
pas un hasard hees a des répercussions
partout même dans les vidéos youtube
loïc le générique voyez ce que je veux
tous les jours la loi de benford
démontre un ordre dans le cas au début
du tube entre autres parce qu'en vrai
youtube ça n'existait pas si je vous
jure que c'est vrai pour sponsoriser
cette vidéo et les gros projets comme
matière grise on est déjà au cinquième
épisode d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas pu
regarder les petites vidéos ci est en
partenariat avec rise of kingdom parce
que dans ce jeu il n'y a pas tellement
de hasard vous allez utiliser vos
stratégies pour changer l'histoire
imaginez que vous ayez le pouvoir de
construire la civilisation française
mais genre la meilleure version arrêter
d'imaginer et télécharger rise up
kingdom savent bien mon lien ci-dessous
défendez la france et obtenez un pacte
pour bien démarrer le jeu au programme
vous allez la france bien sûr mais aussi
dix autres royaumes historiques avec
leurs légendes unités spéciales un style
d'architecturé unique et des bonus pour
chaque civilisation et je vous avoue que
je jouais jeanne d'arc pour combattre
les anglais c'est le feu ma préférence
dans le jeu c'est la stratégie entre les
différents types de terrains combinés
avec la carte qu'ils perdent et alliés
des forces et les faiblesses de chaque
unité il ya un vrai bon moment à jouer
puisque les batailles sont en temps réel
et juste en faisant des orgues holden
draghi bien loïc holden drague c'est
l'axé ans a juste en faisant des roches
de drague sur les troupes vous pouvez
planifier toute votre stratégie on a le
contrôle total de la ville même
esthétiquement d'ailleurs et apparemment
ça plaît pas mal puisque charles willy a
quand même 50 millions de joueurs et le
jeu fait partie des 20 plus téléchargées
sur apple et google store vous pouvez
donc télécharger rise up nous sommes ici
vous obtenez le pack de démarrage le jeu
est gratuit c'est cool
et quand vous passez par mon lien nous
blier jamais ça ça soutient la chaîne
donc ça aussi c'est cool par contre
autant dans le jeu vous maîtrisez tout
autant dans la vie
la loi de benford bat m me percute au
hasard on va faire une expérience très
simple mais complètement folle prenez
par exemple le nombre de vues de toutes
les vidéos youtube d'une chaîne disons
un hasard
la mienne et en même temps vous en
profitez pour vous abonner activer la
cloche ce que tant qu'à faire je sais
que vous l'avez pas fait donc faite le
et pour les vues de la chaîne je vais le
faire moi même
assurez-vous 706 vidéo au moment où
j'écris cette vidéo prenez maintenant le
premier chiffre de tous ces nombres
d'ailleurs ya toutes les vidéos les 706
il ya le nombre de vues à côté on prend
le premier chiffre à chaque fois du
nombre de vues de chacune des 706 vidéo
par exemple premiers chiffres de
celui-ci basse et 1,3 alors oui je sais
ça a pas l'air où flottent benford pour
le moment mais vous allez voir ce que ça
rend à la fin compter maintenant combien
vous avez 2 1 2 2 2 3 2 4 2,5 2,6 2,7 et
2,8 et 2,9 à attendait avant de compter
dites moi dans les commentaires comment
vous pensez que ces chiffres vont être
répartis sur mes 706 vidéo est-ce que
ils seront tous au temps présent est ce
qu'ils apparaîtront toujours la même
fréquence est ce qu'il ya un chiffre qui
va apparaître plus souvent que les
autres parce que les chiffres après le 1
apparaîtront plus que ce avant le 9 fait
le vraiment dites moi dans les
commentaires qu'elle
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'on va avoir
comme résultat beria toutes les vidéos
les 706 et il ya le nombre de vues à
côté on prend le premier chiffre à
chaque fois du nombre de vues de chacune
des 706 vidéo que je vais vous démontrer
dans quelques secondes
logiquement votre cerveau vous a dit que
vous alliez trouver à peu près la même
quantité de 1 2 2 2 3 2 4 et c est bien
qu n'est ni les amis les résultats
obtenus sur les suivants 30% de 1 17 1%
de 2 5% de 3 nuls 6 % de cadres 8,5 pour
cent de 5 7,9 pour cent de 6,5 bull 7%
de cette 5,2 pour cent de 8 et 4 4% de 9
le hasard joue pas si tu prends la
chaîne de quelqu'un d'autre sera 4% de 8
2% 2 1
c'est quoi ok peut-être effectivement
ces chiffres sont clairement un pur
hasard
mais si je vous dis maintenant que vous
obtiendrez quasiment exactement les
mêmes pourcentages avec toutes les
autres chaînes à la condition évidemment
que vous preniez des chaînes youtube qui
ont publié à ces deux vidéos pour avoir
un nombre conséquent pour avoir assez de
données à traiter
calme-toi l'oeil il s'agit en fait de la
loi de benford aussi appelé la loi du
premier chiffre significatif
elle est valable pour énormément de
choses à la d'abord été découverte en
1880 par un astronome mathématicien
économiste statisticien américain
d'origine canadienne serait pas mal et
son nom c'est simone newcombe il
explique dans un article de l'american
journal of mathematics qu'il était en
train de feuilleter un livre de table de
le garric on fait souvent ça tu fais ça
toi ouais bah on feuillette toi on les
lit pas comme les autres françois y est
donc lui aussi d'être en train de
feuilleter son livre sur l'étape de
louga quand il a fait la constatation
que les premières pages étaient moins
viser que les suivantes
et encore que les suivantes et encore
que les suivantes en gros la première
était moins avisés que la deuxième qui
était elle moins moi j'ai que la
troisième etc
il a alors pris d'autres livres et il a
fait la même constatation la
constatation c'est parce que quand il
était astronomique y voyait des
constellations consommation l'article
reste dans les oubliettes jusqu'à ce que
57 ans plus tard en 1938 le physicien
américain frank benford fasse exactement
la même découverte sans connaître le
travail de nuit tombe et y colle son nom
à cette loi effectivement après avoir
collecté les premiers chiffres de vin
série de nombres il se rend compte que
cette loi cole n'ont pas seulement avec
les livres mais avec presque tous les
ensembles de données les longueurs des
rivières quel que soit l'unité de mesure
d'ailleurs en maille sur un kilomètre
les taux de mortalité etc
d'autres confirmations de cette loi vont
ensuite être donné comme avec les
profondeurs des tremblements de terre ou
encore les cas de maladies infectieuses
et cette loi de benford est si précise
que nous savons exactement à quelle
fréquence apparaissent les chiffres et
ça ce n'est pas six variables que ça en
vrai c'est une grosse dinguerie
ça me rend fou évidemment il est
quasiment impossible de tomber pile poil
sur exactement les mêmes pourcentages
pour chaque chiffre mais il est possible
de s'en approcher très fortement et je
vous le promets si vous comparez les
pourcentages d'apparition des chiffres
que je vous ai donné tout à l'heure
condamne analyser les bus de ma chaîne
youtube vous vous regardé les
pourcentages voulez comparer avec les
pourcentages de référence annuel de la
loi de benford c'est hyper troublant
mais c'est très très proche c'est
quasiment exactement ça par contre
attention la loi ne fonctionne pas avec
absolument tout par exemple ne tentez
pas l'expérience avec la taille des
êtres humains
vous auriez la mauvaise surprise de voir
que le nombre 1 revient très souvent
c'est parce que l'on fait souvent entre
1 m et 2 m en fous que brûler pointure
des chaussures le 9 arrive pas souvent
en europe
non il faut prendre des vrais système
aléatoire même chose pour les plaques
d'immatriculation des voitures du coup
les chiffres donnés aux véhicules étant
régulièrement répartit la loi de benford
elle fonctionne pas ou la numérotation
des pages d'un livre
évidemment là comme ça y'a pas
d'aléatoire s'il ya pas d'aléatoire n'ya
pas de bonne forme il semblerait que la
loi se vérifie lorsque les nombres des
ensembles choisi paris sur plusieurs
ordres de grandeurs comme pour les
communes lesquelles peuvent voir leur
nombre d'habitantes constitué de
quelques personnes à plusieurs millions
de personnes
et là ça fonctionne quelle que soit la
taille à quoi ça nous serve sa tinfos
qu'est ce que la loi de benford nous
apporte au quotidien m'a déjà c'est
assez ou vous de savoir ça donc ça a
servi à faire une vidéo sur ma chaîne
youtube là donc ça c'est pas mal mais
ensuite il ya des personnes qui se sont
demandé est ce que la loi de benford se
vérifie toujours si on change les
nombres d'un ensemble sur lequel elle
fonctionne de base
en gros si je modifie volontairement les
données récoltées est ce que ça
fonctionne toujours
par exemple si je trafique l ai vu de ma
chaîne et bien la réponse est non si
vous ne connaissez pas la loi de benford
et que vous changez plusieurs des
chiffres collectés de manière malhonnête
vous allez avoir tendance à vouloir
équilibrer inconsciemment chacun des
chiffres de votre escroquerie hors la
loi elle s'appliquera plus et on va voir
des irrégularités qui vont apparaître et
surtout quand on fait un graphique
comparatif comme la avec les données de
référence regardez les chiffres de ma
chaîne cet escroc de loïc affaire si
fier les données en gonflant un peu les
gros chiffres pour voir ce que ça
donnait ça fait diminuer la proportion
des petits et le pourcentage
d'apparition de chaque chiffre alors
tendance à s'éloigner des pourcentages
de la loi de benford du coup c'est
visible la courbe s'éloigne de ce à quoi
devrait ressembler au départ il est donc
possible de déceler un ensemble de
chiffres falsifiés a
être de cette loi et qui donc a bien pu
se dire qu'il y avait un intérêt à
utiliser sa belle le contrôleur des
impôts et des fraudes évidemment car oui
ça fonctionne aussi sur un cahier de
compta de levallois par exemple voila
voila connaissait pas benford dans ce
cas là des impôts utilise la loi juste
comme un outil indicateurs pour voir
s'ils peuvent déceler une éventuelle
fraude
et si ils voient ça il ya une analyse
évidemment plus poussée qui bien sûr a
effectué ensuite par la suite pour voir
si oui ou non il ya eu fraude ou
malversation ou s'il s'agissait
peut-être d'une exception à la loi de
benford un calcul a même été créé pour
connaître le degré d' éloignement de la
loi de benford acceptable afin de savoir
si un ensemble de nombres analyse et
doit être considérée ou non comme
suspect comme modifier comme trafiqués
mais y'a pas claque ça sert en 2013
les votes aux élections électorales du
canton de genève en suisse ont été
soumis à la loi de benford afin de voir
si les résultats étaient conformes à la
loi
ce qui n'a pas été le cas et là le test
a été pris en compte comme un indicateur
puisque comme un signal d'alarmé et la
chancellerie on a ensuite conclu en
vérifiant que les résultats étaient
simplement inhabituel mais qu'ils
étaient ok donc a eu aucun problème
entaché le processus de vote mais comme
ça ils ont pu jeter un oeil le monde de
la science s'est aussi penché sur le
sujet notamment en analysant les nombres
publié dans des articles scientifiques
afin de voir si avec d'éventuelles
erreurs encore plus fort en espagne les
vulcanologues
rony martias et adélie naqd rigueur je
crois que je prononce bien se sont
également penchés sur son utilisation de
la loi et l'ont testé sur leurs bases de
données
et ça fonctionne et du coup si cette loi
fonctionne sur des événements aussi
naturel que des éruptions volcaniques ou
des tremblements de terre
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas complété à
l'avance la suite de nombres à analyser
de manière à ce que la loi de benford
continue à se vérifier et qu'on puisse
peut-être prédire les futures
catastrophes naturelles c'est une vraie
question et certaines personnes sont
assez sceptiques sur le côté mystique de
cette loi et ont tenté d'apporter une
explication un peu rationnelle à ce
phénomène
nous comptons à partir du chiffre 1
logique donc il serait tout à fait aussi
logique qu'il soit le premier à
apparaître plus de fois que les autres
idem pour les chiffres suivantes
jusqu'au 9 qui lui est le dernier à
paraître con compte et qui apparaîtra
donc logiquement au moins souvent que
les autres 30% de 1 17% de 2 etc dans
tous les cas ça n'empêchera pas de
penser que ce monde et cet univers sont
assez incroyables dans leurs petits
réglages sous jacent qu'on met le nez
dedans je sais pas pour vous mais
personnellement ça me retourne le
cerveau
de savoir que des chiffres aussi
improbable il y ait parfois des
décisions totalement arbitraire en fait
où est ce qu'on appelle des hasards de
la vie ou encore simplement la nature
le hasard de la nature puisse être aussi
correctement ranger en catégorie de
pourcentage merci encore également à
rise of kingdoms d'avoir accepté ce
partenariat n'oubliez pas de tester le
jeu en téléchargeant des gammes on lire
dans la description et faites-vous une
partie pour voir par vous même
c'est le meilleur argument essayez vous
même c'est gratuit bref comme toujours
je m'appelle fabien olicard ça ça va pas
changer abonnez vous à cette chaîne
c'est gratuit pensez à activer la cloche
si vous voulez voir passer les
prochaines vidéos n'hésitez pas à liker
cette vidéo si vous avez regardé
jusqu'ici ici je vous mets une vidéo sur
un concours marrant de calcul mental
qu'on avait faits est ici une vidéo sur
le baromètre de bord à très bientôt
ciao